und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend das sind eindrückliche
bilder die uns heute ausbilder russ
erreichen wenn alexander lukaschenko
gehofft hatte dass es bei dieser wahl
läuft wie immer ein paar proteste die er
brutal niederschlagen lässt und dann
herrscht wieder ruhe
so hat er sich getäuscht zwei wochen
nach der sogenannten wahl in belarus
gingen heute wieder zehntausende auf die
straße
trotz massiven aufgebots von polizei und
militär haben die menschen straßen und
plätze gefüllt
nicht nur in der hauptstadt minsk auch
in anderen teilen des landes wird
protestiert und gestreckt derweil lehnt
lukaschenko weiterhin jeden dialog ab
für begann berichtet ist das eine
machtdemonstration oder der verzweifelte
versuch macht zu demonstrieren
in schusssicherer weste und mit
kalaschnikow tauchte alexander
lukaschenko am abend vor seinem
ministeramt sitz auf mit helm an seiner
seite sein 15 jähriger sohn verbreitet
werden diese bilder von einem
regierungstreuen social media kanal
währenddessen füllen diejenigen die sich
ein ende dieses regimes wünschen die
zentralen straßen der hauptstadt
sie fordern generationenübergreifend ein
leben in freiheit
lukaschenko wenn du das land nicht
regieren kannst dann hau ab schau dir an
wie viele junge leute hier sind las sie
leben als ich heute mit meiner mutter
her gekommen bin haben wir gesehen dass
da drüben sehr viele gefangenen
transporter stehen
so sollte es in einem freien land nicht
sein das militär hat lukaschenko in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt soldaten und
polizisten stehen mit schwerem gerät den
demonstranten gegenüber die friedlich
durch minsk ziehen
der neueste versuch die belarussische
demokratiebewegung als gefährliche vom
ausland gesteuerte kraft darzustellen
kommt heute aus moskau vom russischen
außenminister wichtig ist dass es kein
provozieren von unruhen von außen gibt
die lage beruhigt sich jetzt aber wir
wissen genau dass das nicht alle gut
finden
sein volk gegen sich aufbringen das
schafft lukaschenko auch ganz alleine
auseinander gelaufen wie ratten spottet
er die schätzungsweise 100.000 die sich
heute einmal mehr nicht von seinem
sicherheitsapparat einschüchtern ließen
muss er dabei übersehen haben
belarussen die genug haben von
gewaltherrschaft und demütigung und so
kämpfen die belarussen für das was für
uns selbstverständlich und manchen
geradezu lästig ist tatsächlich eine
wahl zu haben
in diesem corona sommer bringen sich die
deutschen parteien dabei auf
unterschiedliche weise ins gespräch bei
der union beugen sich weiter zwei
ministerpräsidenten im pandemie modus
bei der fdp fliegt die generalsekretäre
bei der afg fliegen fäuste
die spd ruft vorsorglich schon mal einen
kanzlerkandidaten aus und die grünen
surfen eher still durch die sommerpause
und versuchen möglichst geschmeidig
unangenehme fragen nach
kanzlerkandidatur und koalitionsoptionen
zu umschiffen beobachtungen dazu von
thomas reich das gerät etwas in bewegung
am ende dieser langen parlamentsferien
mehr als ein jahr vor der wahl wird
vorgefühlt zum beispiel so geht
demnächst eine regierung ohne die union
im zdf sommerinterview in frankfurt oder
schließt annalena baerbock nun auch eine
ampel mit spd und fdp nicht aus
natürlich kann ich mehr dreier
konstellation auch vorstellen wir
regieren in etlichen bundesländern mit
der fdp in der in dreier konstellation
wir haben seit jahren gesagt wir
schließen keine demokratische
kombination aus die grünen drängen an
die macht 15 jahre opposition haben sie
so ungeduldig wie beweglich gemacht
alles scheint nun zu gehen sogar ein
bündnis mit der fdp
die bekommt nun ein generalsekretär der
anders als parteichef lindner wenig
grüne vorbehalte hat gemeint sogar mit
grün regiert und nun auch die fühler
ausstreckt ich habe in rheinland pfalz
sehr gute erfahrungen gemacht hat hat
man von anfang an offen miteinander
gesprochen und die fdp kann in
rheinland-pfalz liberale politik
umsetzen
mehr kann man als politiker der freien
demokraten nicht erreicht
was geht was könnte gehen es ist das
lieblings ratespiel im berliner
regierungsviertel
und die spd hat es mit olaf scholz mit
der vorgepreschten kandidaten verkündung
ordentlich angeheizt
wir als spd sagen ganz klar
gemeinsamkeiten mit der union sind
aufgebraucht insofern beobachten wir was
passiert bei der fdp wir beobachten was
passiert bei der linkspartei
es ist irgendwie klar das ist
mittlerweile ja viele politische akteure
gibt die wollen eine regierung ohne die
union wie gesagt ist gerät etwas in
bewegung am ende von merkels
kanzlerschaft am ende der alten
sitzverteilung plötzlich scheint viel
möglich zumindest im gedankenspiel
gedankenspiele in einer zeit in der so
vieles ungewiss ist
wenn es die nächste bundestagswahl
planmäßig im herbst 21 gibt die wird es
deutschland dann gehen wird die pandemie
bis dahin vorbei seien oder zumindest im
griff davon sind im moment noch weit
entfernt
rund 800.000 corona tote weltweit meldet
die johns hopkins universität in
deutschland konferieren morgen die
gesundheitsminister der länder da wird
es unter anderem um bundeseinheitliche
regelungen für veranstaltungen gehen und
außerdem wird über das masken tragen
debattiert diese und andere meldungen
rund um corona hat jana becker
zusammengestellt in unserem corona
dicker
das bundesgesundheitsministerium
reagiert heute auf die diskussion um
labor engpässe bei corona tests ein
sprecher des ministeriums teilte auf zdf
anfrage hin mit die theoretischen
laborkapazitäten seien zwar noch nicht
erreicht aber auf dauer stoße das system
an seine grenzen
die test strategie müsse nach dem urlaub
zurück reisen entsprechend angepasst
werden daran arbeite das ministerium
bereits mit hochdruck
kilometerlanger stau an das slowenische
österreichischen grenze auch viele
deutsche urlauber mussten in der
vergangenen nacht bis zu zwölf stunden
lang warten
aufgrund steigender corona
infektionszahlen in kroatien hatte
österreich alle durchreisenden erfasst
am morgen lockt hatten die behörden ihre
kontrollen
die debatte um eine bundesweite masken
pflicht am arbeitsplatz hat cdu-chefin
kramp karrenbauer heute in der welt am
sonntag aufgenommen dies könne ein
schritt sein wenn damit die schließung
ganzer branchen verhindert werden könnte
doch der vorschlag stößt auch auf kritik
der deutsche gewerkschaftsbund warnt vor
blindem aktionismus
und jetzt die nachrichten von heinz wolf
nachdem der russische kremlkritiker
alexander war nie zur medizinischen
behandlung nach berlin gebracht wurde
gab es heute keine neuen informationen
zu seinem gesundheitlichen zustand und
auch nicht zu den spekulationen über
eine mögliche vergiftung eine eigentlich
geplante informationsveranstaltung
seines teams wurde abgesagt vizekanzler
olaf scholz hofft auf eine erfolgreiche
behandlung japan ließ in deutschland
gegenüber der neuen westfälischen sagte
er demokraten könnten es nicht
akzeptieren dass das leben von
oppositionellen in gefahr gebracht werde
navalny liegt seit gestern im berliner
krankenhaus charité
der 44 jährige war vor drei tagen ins
koma gefallen seine frau und freunde
befürchten dass er vergiftet wurde
nach heftigen unwetter an der türkischen
schwarzmeerküste sind sechs menschen bei
überschwemmungen ums leben gekommen
mindestens zehn werden noch vermisst
die wassermassen haben autos und trümmer
mitgerissen und häuser und straßen
zerstört
meteorologen rechnen zudem mit weiteren
unwetter und im us bundesstaat
kalifornien kämpfen tausende
feuerwehrleute weiter gegen verheerende
brände
fünf menschen kamen bereits ums leben
etwa 120.000 menschen wurden angewiesen
ihre häuser zu verlassen und sich in
sicherheit zu bringen
drei riesige feuer und sich kleinere
mittlerweile haben die flammen insgesamt
etwa 4000 quadratkilometern zerstört bei
san jose bietet der zweitgrößte brand in
der geschichte kaliforniens viele stehen
vor dem nichts
zu beginn der katastrophe haben die
nachbarn wie eine familie zusammen
gehalten
jetzt sind alle irgendwo verstreut
auslöser für die heftigen brände waren
vor allem tausende blitzeinschläge hitze
und trockenheit fachten die flammen
weiter an
wenn sie nicht an den klimawandel
glauben kommen sie nach kalifornien
twitter der gouverneur des staates in
die welt wir leben echt in verrückten
zeiten vor fünf jahren gab es noch nicht
jedes jahr so heftige feuer und jetzt
gibt es jedes jahr einen neuen rekord
jedes jahr bis dienstag erwarten die
einsatzkräfte neue blitzeinschläge und
den ausbruch war
es wird also womöglich noch schlimmer
kommen
und jetzt mal kurz die wetteraussichten
zum start in die neue woche
morgen von norden bis zur mitte oft
stärker bewölkt mit schauern im norden
auch mit kurzen gewittern
im süden länger sonnig und trocken 18
bis 24 grad
in den nächsten tagen im norden schauer
im süden meist trocken am mittwoch an
den küsten stürmisch höchstwerte von 18
bis 28 grad
das war es auch schon von uns weiter
gehts mit der zweiten halbzeit wieder
sind
[Musik]